so when I was a young sales guy in the
real estate business I used to listen to
all the motivational speakers and some
of them are excellent some of them are
really not people you care anything
about what they say
and later on I've gotten to meet a few
of them and have become friends with
them and it's kind of neat to get to
meet your heroes one of those has got
name Les Brown if you ever get the
chance to listen to last year I look up
some of his talks he's absolutely
amazing african-american gentleman he
can peel the paint off the walls baby
when he's speaking I mean you come out
there fired up absolutely amazing and
then later on lesson I actually got to
share the stage together in Los Angeles
we did an event together there on the
same radio station at one time and it's
just a great guy but let's have a you
know one of the sayings I use all the
time is if you're sick and tired of
being sick and tired then you're ready
to change people to only change their
lives when they finally say I've had it
that's a Les Brown quote and he used to
say something else that if you're gonna
win in any area of your life and just
generally in your life you have to be
not hungry but hungry that was the way
he said it I like that because it's a
little more visceral right you have to
be hungry you have to you have to have
this desire to win and you know I'm just
reading a book by a friend of mine
Patrick Lencioni the ideal team player
when you're hiring team players they
need three virtues three attributes that
they have when you're hiring them one of
them is they need to have this hunger
they need to be hungry you got to be
hungry man and let me just tell you
people that that intellectually want to
change things
they're think-tank goups they don't get
anything done people that intellectually
want to change their lives they don't
change anything
the
when people get viscerally involved
their emotions and their soul is
speaking they're hungry that's when they
change things you know that's what I
wanna challenge you do with your money
the people who get out of debt the
people who are able to build wealth in
the culture today that we live in
they're everywhere they're everywhere
but one of the characteristics one of
the virtues they share just like an
ideal team player shares this virtue is
with our home brain so you can't you
know being hungry is a decision it's a
work ethic thing but it's a motor that's
running down inside of you I will not be
denied the kind of a thing happening
inside of you and so when you lay out
your get out of debt plan when you have
your budget with your spouse if you're
married or not married you lay it out a
single when you when you lay out your
plan you got to get hungry and hungry
means you're gonna do what it takes to
win this debt is going down we're gonna
amputate the Tahoe we're gonna sell so
much stuff the kids think they're next
we're gonna put the dog on eBay and the
cat on Craigslist I mean there's stuff
gonna move around here cuz I'm hungry
something's got to change
something's got to move my life is not
okay I got to change some stuff in my
marriage I got to change some stuff in
my physical condition I got to change
some stuff in the way I attack at work
and the way I get things done and the
level of the level of bring it and
ownership I have it work the level of
complete a project with excellence and a
smile at work the way you do things you
got to be hungry man and you know when
you do that it changes everything you
know I'm not saying you have to be fired
up and run around the hair on fire all
the time but it's a thing down inside
it's a hard thing it's not a head thing
and people who are high performers in
anything in the area of their lives
we call them successful they're hungry
and you know what you can just decide
today to be hungry be hungry starting
right now go for it baby that's how it's
done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind